اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام حاله اقرب الى
الركود منها الى الحرار سواء على المسار
السياسي او على جبهات القتال مازال فرقاء
الازمه الليبيه يتراشقون بشكل متقطع
يتراشقون بالاتهامات بانتهاك وقف اطلاق
النار الذي تختلف مرجعياتهم بشانه لكن ذلك
لا يرقى الى الصوره السائده ايام المعارك
الطاحنه فهل سكوت الاليات العسكريه دليل
على ان شيئا ما يتفاعل وراء الستار وهل
يقود ذلك ليبيا والليبيين الى هدوء وسلام
طال الحنين اليهما وما دلالات توقيت نفي
رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله ان تكون
اجتماعات بوزنج في المغرب قد ناقشت قضايا
تتعلق بنقل المؤسسات الى خارج العاصمه او
بتركيبه المجلس الرئاسي او اختيار اعضائه
ما فرص نجاح باريس في جمع فرقاء الازمه
الليبيه بدا واضحا في الاونه الاخيره ان
الاطراف السياسيه الليبيه في شرق البلاد
وغربها رجعت الى دائره الحوار للبحث عن حل
سياسي ينهي الصراع المسلح ويضع حدا
للمراحل الانتقاليه التي عمقت الانقسام
وادخلت البلاد في نفق فوضى وحروب انهكت
الجميع دون استثناء رئيس المجلس الاعلى
للدوله في ليبيا خالد المشري يؤكد الرغبه
في انهاء المرحله الانتقاليه من خلال
الاستفتاء على الدستور واجراء انتخابات
برلمانيه ورئاسه نزيهه وشفافه وقال المشري
ان الطريق لانهاء المرحله الانتقاليه لا
يكون الا بحوار ينهي الانقسام السياسي
ويوحد المؤسسات ويقضي على اي تهديد لسياده
الدوله ووحدتها ونفى التطرق مطلقا بشكل
رسمي لنقل المؤسسات خارج العاصمه او
لتركيبه المجلس الرئاسي او اختيار
اعضائه وفي سياق تفاعلات المشهد الليبي
وتجهيزه لمرحله الحوار بين اطرافه
السياسيه ذكر موقع انتلجنس اون لاين ان
فرنسا وجهت الدعوه لابرز اربع شخصيات في
مشهد الازمه وهم فائز السراج وعقيله صالح
وفتحي باشاغا وخليفه حفتر فيما يبدو انها
محاوله فرنسيه لفتح مسار حوار يفضي الى
نوع من التوافق مع انه عرف عن الدور
الفرنسي في ليبيا انه داعم لحفتر وهذا
يدعو الى القول ان فرنسا قد تكون راغبه
في اعاده تدوير حفتر لتجنيبه اي عقوبات
دوليه وابقائه لاعبا رئيسيا في المشهد
الليبي رغم هزيمته المدويه في الحرب التي
شنها على
طرابلس وفي حديث للجزيره قال غالب الزقلعي
المتحدث باسم رئيس المجلس الرئاسي ان
السراج تلقى دعوه لزياره فرنسا لم يحدد
موعدها بعد لكنه اكد ان زياره السراج
لفرنسا لا تتضمن اللقاء بحفظ
الذي يصفه السراج
بالمنقلة منذ قرابه ثلاثه اعوام كان فيها
الرصاص سيد
المشهد ارحب بضيفي اللذان الذين انضما الي
في هذا النقاش من مراطه المحلل السياسي
الاستاذ فيصل الشريف ومن سياتل عبر
الانترنت الدكتور ابراهيم هيبه استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه والسياسات المقارنه في
جامعه شمال تكساس الامريكيه مرحبا بكما
وسؤالنا للسيد فيصل الشريف سيد فيصل هل
جرت مياه جديده في الازمه الليبيه هل في
الافق امكانات لحل حله الركود الحاصل
فيها نعم اخي محمود تحيه طيبه لك ولضيفك
ومشاهدي ك الافاضل نعم اذا اذا يعني اذا
ما اردنا ان ان نتحدث في سياق هذه الم
المستجدات وهذا وهذه الحركات السياسيه
التي تحصل اليوم ما حدث في بوزني وما حدث
في مونتيرو في في جينيف اتصور ان بالفعل
نص نطيع ان نقول ان هناك انفراجات الى حد
ما من خلال تسريبات الكثير من اللقاءات
التي حصلت هناك تسريبات على الهامش او
تسريبات ربما حتى يعني شخصيه تمكنا من
الحصول عليها من بعض الاطراف الذين حضروا
في سواء في في جينيف او او في يعني
بوزنيقه كل هذه المؤشرات تتحدث عن ان
المجتمع الدولي واراده سياسيه في الداخل
وكذلك يعني تماشيا وتماهي مع المظاهره
التي تحدث على المستوى الشعبي في ليبيا في
كل القطر الليبي او في كل الدوله الليبيه
هذه السياقات اصبحت هي التي تضغط في اتجاه
ان الفرقاء يجب ان يجتمعوا واجتمعوا
بالفعل بعد الماراتون الطويل الذي رايناه
قد حصل في تونس وانقطع ودخل وحصل الاعتداء
على العاصمه و والكل يعني الكل التزم
الصمت والمجتمع الدولي كذلك شارك في هذه
العمليه اليوم نرى ان المجتمع الدولي قد
يائس بالفعل من ان يكون هناك حل عسكري
للازمه الليبيه بالتالي نرى الاطراف الان
اصبحت اكثر قربا من بعضها من خلال الاتفاق
السياسي ونص الماده 15 وغيره يعني الحديث
يتجه الى ان الجسمين المنوط بهما يعني
الوصول الى توافقات وتفاهمات هما المجلس
الاعلى للدوله والبرلمان بالتالي ما نتج
عن هذه الحوارات المبدئيه التمهيديه سواء
في بوزنيقه او في جنيف كله يعني يصب في
مصب واحد وهو ان الجميع اصبح واثقا من انه
لا من
من الوصول الى حل
يعني ينقلنا من هذا يعني من هذا المستوى
الذي نحن فيه والذي يهدد بمظاهرات شامله
ويهدد ربما بفتح الابواب علىك على كامل
مصرعيها في اتجاهات مجهوله وكذلك بفوضى
عارمه بالتالي الكل اليوم اصبح امام حقيقه
واضحه هو اننا ماضون الى حل سياسي وتقسيم
ل ربما للسلطه ما بين هذه الاجسام
السياسيه المفت
طيب دكتور دكتور ابراهيم اذا كنت تتفق مع
السيد فيصل الشريف في تفاؤله بان هناك حلا
سياسيا يلوح في الافق هل تتفضل وتوضح لنا
ملامح هذا الحل اذا كنت متفقا مع وجهه
النظر
هذه اهلا بك استاذ استاذ محمود واهلا
بضيوفك الكرام انا في تقديري نعم يعني
هناك ضغوط محليه من من داخل ليبيا هناك
ايضا مساعي الامم المتحده لتقريب وجهات
النظر بين الاطراف المتصارعه داخل ليبيا
وايضا هناك رغبه من بعض القوى الدوليه في
دفع الليبيين نحو طاوله الحوار بالرغم انه
لا تزال هناك في تقدير
خلافات دوليه بالتحديد من قبل الدول
المتدخله بشان في في الشان الداخلي الليبي
بشكل مباشر او اصبحت لديها اجندات او
مصالح تلزمها ب يعني بمتابعه
وب باهتمام الوضع الداخلي الليبي وما يؤول
اليه في المستقبل منها على سبيل المثال
الدوله التركيه منها الاتحاد الاوروبي او
والدوله الفرنسيه والالمانيه والانيه
اسالك عن عن ملامح ملامح الحل الذي يمكن
ان ينطبق على الحاله الليبيه ذكر ضيف هنا
الاستاذ فيصل الشريف ان هناك مظاهرات تعوم
القطري الليبي كله من شرقه الى غربه مؤخرا
في الشرق ومن قبل ذلك كانت في الغرب لكن
هذه المظاهرات لم تكن تدعو الى حل بقدر ما
كانت تحتج على الفساد ونقص الخدمات وما
الى ذلك بمعنى اصح تدعو الى رحيل
الطبقه الحاكمه الطبقه النافذه المؤثره
والقيادات الحاليه واستبدال قيادات اصلح
بها هو هو في الحقيقه يعني هناك شيئين
يعني الشيء الاول وهو مطالب الناس مطالب
الناس كما اشرت حضرتك يعني تنادي برحيل
كافه الموجودين على الساحه السياسيه و
وهذه المطالب ناتجه عن عن عن القصر في
تقديم الخدمات للمواطن الليبي وانعدام
الامن والامان وانعدام الخدمات بشكل كامل
وهذه هي مطالب الناس
لكن الذي من الناحيه الواقعيه في تقديري
ان مطالب الناس لا يمكن تحقيقها بشكل كامل
بالشكل الذي يرغب به الناس ولكن في تقديري
الان التوجه السياسي ما بين الاطراف
السياسيه المتسارعه نحو مرحله انتقاليه
جديده وهو محاوله وضع اتفاق سياسي جديد او
تعديل الاتفاق السياسي الموجود الان
بحيث تذهب الدوله الليبيه نحو مرحله
انتقاليه جديده هذه هذا هذه البروسيس وهذه
العمليه بدات يعني بالحوارات التمه في في
المغرب والحوارات التمهيديه ايضا في في في
سويسرا ولكن لا يزال في
تقديري الحوارات تزال في بدايتها ولا ولا
يزال المشهد معقد في تقديري و ومرجح لكل
الاحتمالات ولكن في تقديري اذا اخذنا
مقارنه ما بين ما يحدث الان ومقارنه
باتفاق السخيرات اتفاق السخيرات اخذ
تقريبا 18 شهر من اجل الصول الليبيين الى
ذلك الاتفاق المعيب الذي زاد من تعقيد
المشهد السياسي والامني في ليبيا وادى الى
هذه الحرب الاهليه في تقدير ولكن الان
الليبيين لديهم رغبه حقيقيه في محاوله
اصلاح الاتفاق السياسي انا في تقديري ان
هذا سياخذ وقت ايضا وقت طويل قد ياخذ سنه
او اقل او اككثر
الليبيون على يقفون على
اعتاب عذرا سيدي سيد فيصل الشريف الان يقف
الفرقاء الليبيون على اعتاب ما يمكن ان
يسمى مبادره فرنسيه لحل حاله هذه الازمه
ما الذي يمكن لفرنسا ان تقدمه حل ازمه هي
منحازه اشد الانحياز لاحد
طرفيها نعم سؤال جيد اخي محمود الحقيقه
يعني الليبيون اليوم اخي محمود امام يعني
ربما سيناريوهين لا ثالث لهما الحل
المثالي يرى الليبيون والشارع الليبي في
في في في جله يتوجه الى انه يريد ان يتخلص
من كل هذه الاجسام ومن كل هذه الوجوه هذا
الحل المثالي لا يتاتى الا باستفتاء على
دستور ثم المرور الى انتخابات برلمانيه
ورئاسه هذا الحل المثالي هذا الحل المثالي
في تصوري الان غير متاح وبالتالي نتحدث عن
الحل الواقعي الذي يتحدث عن توحيد
المؤسسات بدايه ثم الانطلاق الى هذا الحل
المثالي الذي ينشده الليبيون اما ما يتعلق
بما ورد على انتليجنس اون لاين وما
والحديث عن ان فرنسا تحاول ان تزج بنفسها
اليوم لمحاوله خلط الاوراق في تصوري ان
فرنسا على مدى السنين الفارط الكل دركه
بان فرنسا لا تملك حلولا تقدمها لليبيين
وانما دائما وابدا تسعى الى خلط المشهد
وتقديم العون لخليفه حفتر وانعاشه من جديد
ومحاوله خلط الاوراق حتى تعود فرص خليفه
حفتر من جديد لان ينطلق نحو يعني ربما نحو
يعني تحقيق هذه الطموحات التي ترغب فيها
فرنسا والامارات من خلفها اذا اخي محمود
السؤال هنا الذي يطرح نفسه ما مدى جديه
المجتمع الدولي هذا هذه المره نحن نعرف ان
دول كبرى وفاعله مثل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه التي دعت بشكل واضح الى حل
افراغ سرت والجفره من من المظاهر المسلحه
واستغلال سرت في نقل اغلب المؤسسات
السياسيه
والسيادة المتصاعد اليوم يشي بشيء واحد ان
هناك اراده دوليه صادقه اليوم هناك اراده
محليه اعتقد ايضا صادقه في انه انف الز
انف اليوم يعني يكفي يكفي بكل معنى الكلمه
الليبيون وصلوا الى مرحله سيئه على جميع
الاصعده لا مجال لاعاده
تدوير هذه الوجوه من جديد لا مجال للجلوس
و يعني وتعشي او يعني تعيش الليبيين على
الاماني ومحاوله يعني د عواطفهم ببيان هنا
وبيان هناك حاله الفساد تنامت بشكل كبير
الحاله السياسيه اصبحت سيئه بكل ومن ضيفي
الكريم من الولايات المتحده حتى نستطيع ان
نستفيد بالوقت المتبقي سؤالنا للدكتور
ابراهيم هيبه على ذكر مساله اعاده تدوير
بعض القيادات قال السيد فيصل الشريف ان
هناك محاوله فرنسيه
لاعاده تلميع الجنرال خليفه حفتر ودفعه
مره اخرى الى العمليه السياسيه هل اعتقد
فعلا ان هذا هو الهدف من فرنسا هناك من
يتحدث عن محاولات فرنسيه للتقرب من حكومه
الوفاق من الطرف الموجود في طرابلس لقطع
الطريق على اي دور تركي بالنظر او لفهم
هذا في سياق التوتر الحاصل بين تركيا
وفرنسا في الكثير من الملفات هل توافق على
هذا نعم انا اوافق على الجزء الاخير الذي
ذكرته يعني المساله ليست مساله متعلقه
باعاده تدوير السيد حفتر او ا اعا اعادته
للمشهد السياسي كما تفضل ضيفي الكريم ولكن
المساله متعلقه بالصراع الذي دائر الان في
المتوسط الذي كان سببه هو الاخذ تركيا
بزمان مبادره وتوقيع اتفاقيه ما بين حكومه
السران وما بين دوله التركيه التي حدثت
جدلا كبيرا على المستوى الدولي والاقليمي
وحتى الداخلي حول شرعيه هذه الاتفاقيه و
واعطت تركيا لنفسها الحق في التنقيب على
الغاز والبترول في البحر الابيض المتوسط
الذي اثار حفيظه الاوروبيين بشكل كبير و
وقلقهم خصوصا وان تركيا الان تحاول ان
تلعب ان ان ان تهيمن على المشهد السياسي
او تكون لها نفوذ كبير على طرابلس على اقل
تقدير في في ليبيا هذه المساله اثارت
حفيظه الاوروبيين وبالتحديد الدوله
الفرنسيه التي هي الدوله القائد في
الاتحاد الاوروبي مع الدوله الالمانيه
وبالتالي في تقديري محاوله الدوله
الفرنسيه جمع الاطراف الليبيه للحوار داخل
داخل فرنسا او جمع مطه حوار في فرنسا هو
الهدف منه هو محاوله تحجيم الد الدور
التركي ومحاوله يعني ان يكون للدوله
الفرنسيه والاتحاد الاوروبي ايضا كلمه ونف
فود على ما يحدث في ليبيا واعاده الامور
الى نصابها وفق المفهوم الاوروبي ومفهوم
المفهوم الفرنسي من هذا الجانب لا اعتقد
ان الموضوع متعلق بحفتر او اعاده تدوير
السيد حفتر كما اشار ضيفك الكريم ولكن
مساله متعلقه بالصراع الدائر الان في في
البحر الابيض المتوسط حول استكشافات
البترول والتنقيب على الغاز في البحر
المتوسط من جانب اخر في تقديري يعني فرنسا
كانت ولا تزال مستثمر كبير في ليبيا هي
التي استثمرت في اسقاط نظام القذافي وهي
استثمرت ما بعد اسقاط نظام القذافي في
محاوله لاعاده موضعها في في في في ليبيا
من خلال استثمارات في مجالات البترول التي
في تقديري حتى الان لم تتحصل على على
النتائج اللي كانت مج من هذه الاستثمارات
دكتور ابراهيم بحسب كلامك في لقاءات سابقه
قلت ان ان ان الجنرال خليفه حفتر وهو رجل
فرنسا في الحقيقه في في ليبيا يحاول ان
يعيد الدور الذي كان يلعبه القذافي يحاول
محاكاه القذافي في ليبيا ولذلك خسر شعبيته
او فشل في مشروعه السياسي وال والعسكري
يعني فرنسا في نهايه المطاف لم تراهن على
الحصان الذي يمكن ان يحظى بشعبيه لدى
الليبيين وانا لا اعتقد لا اتفق معك ان ان
السيد حفتر هو رجل فرنسا في ليبيا انا
اعتقد ان ان السيد حفتر لديه حلفاء يعني
كثر من ضمنهم الدوله الروسيه من ضمنهم
الدوله الفرنسيه من ضمنهم يعني بعض الدول
العربيه مصر الامارات يعني هناك وحتى
يرتبط بعلاقات في تقديري خاصه مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وفي تقديري ان سيد حفتر
يحاول ان يلعب على التناقضات ولكنه قد
يوفق في بعض الاحيان ولا يوفق في كثير من
الاحيان ولكن في تقديري المساله المتعلقه
الان هو بالدور الفرنسي في ليبيا والادوار
الدوليه الاخرى التي تلعبها دول اخرى في
الصراع السياسي في ليبيا للاسف الشديد
يعني القوه السياسيه المتسارعه الداخليه
فقدت لزمام المبادره واصبحت يعني ما دائر
في ليبيا هو عباره عن بروكسي وور وتدخلات
خارجيه من قبل قوى لديها مصالح وترى ان
لديها مصالح استراتيجيه في ليبيا وبالتالي
القوى السياسيه فقدت لزمان مبادله اصبحت
عباره عن ممثل لهذه
القوه منطقه الشرق الاوسط او في اوروبا او
في الع ن نعم دكتور ابراهيم عذرا على
المقاطعه عذرا على المقاطعه باختصار سيد
فيصل الشريف فرنسا نجحت من قبل في جمع
فرقاء الازمه الليبيه بطرفها في باريس عام
2018 من دون اي جدوى تلاح ملاحظه هل تعتقد
ان هناك جديدا في ما يمكن ان يقال عنه
مبادره فرنسيه
راهنه يعني صدقني اخي محمود انا اختلف
جمله وتفصيله مع ما تفضل به ضيفك الكريم
فيما يتعلق بالموقف الفرنسي المتتبع
للموقف الفرنسي يعني منذ يعني ربما منذ
2014 واعلان انقلاب خليفه حفتر كان موقفا
يعني مصمما على الهذه يقود ال يعني من
الخلف ما يقوم به الجنرال حفتر ب بطريق
استعماريه بشعه بتزويده بالاسلحه وكذلك
تزويده يعني بالخبراء العسكريين وفضيحه
جافل خير دليل في غريان والكثير من
الشواهد التي حصلت التي تبيت بشكل واضح
بان يعني فرنسا مصممه على ان يكون دورها
دورا مشبوه في ليبيا مصممه على ان تعبث
باوراق الليبيين مصممه دائما على افساد
الحاله السياسيه حتى ما عقدته او ما عقد
في في باريس من مؤتمر كان مجرد يعني نوع
من خلط الاوراق لان حتى استدعاء خليفه
حفتر والتماهي معه كان اصرارا فرنسيا على
التماهي مع خليفه حفتر والضرب بعرض الحائط
اتفاق الصخيرات الذي يستبعد خليفه حفتر
بالتالي اصرت يعني فرنسا معيه الامارات
وغيرها من الدول المتورطه في ليبيا على
نهج ذات السياسه فرنسا لن تغير شيء فرنسا
لازالت الطرف السلبي في المعادله ولازالت
تصر على خط الا قد يكون الاخير في هذه
الفقره دكتور ابراهيم
في في صالح من يلعب عامل الوقت دون حل او
دون تحريك للمياه الراكده في الازمه
الليبيه في
تقديرك انا في تقديري يعني هناك كثير من
الاطراف التي تعول على الوقت لان الوقت قد
يخلق يخلط الاوراق وقد ينتج معادله سياسيه
مختلفه خصوصا في ظل الانسداد الذي يراه
بعض انه ليس في صالحه الان وبالتالي في
تقديري العامل الوقت هو مضر لليبيين للشعب
الليبي بالدرجه الاولى لان كل يوم يمر من
معاناه الشعب الليبي يحسب على الشعب
الليبي بالنسبه للاطراف السياسيه بشكل عام
يعني يعني ترى او ترغب او لديها منطلق
عقلاني تريد ان نستمر في السلطه وبالتالي
سوف تحاول ان لن تكون جديه في عمليه
التفاوض عمليه ايجاد الحل في في في ليبيا
وبالتالي مصلحتها في البقاء في السلطه
الدكتور ابراهيم هيبه استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه والسياسات المقارنه في جامعه شمال
تكساس الامريكيه كان معنا من سياتل واشكر
ضيفي من مصرا
المحلل السياسي الاستاذ فيصل الشريف
مشاهدينا الاعزاء وصلنا الى نهايه الحصاد
شكرا جزيلا لكم على حسن المتابعه السلام
[موسيقى]
عليكم